Gentlemen, have you ever seen a cocky guy
at a bar and thought, “Man I can’t stand
that guy, why do women like him?”
They don’t, but you’re not giving them
another option by sitting over there and moping.
Hello guys and of course, ladies, this episode
is for you too.
Julian here for DNews.
A new study from the University of Queensland
offers a new answer for why overconfident
men at bars and clubs seem to be more successful.
The study had over 3000 men and women create
dating profiles which were rated by the opposite
sex.
Subjects researchers identified as confident
came across as either confident, which was
appealing, or arrogant, which wasn’t.
Nobody likes that guy, c’mon.
And the women in the study agreed.
That is until the men had the option to compete
with each other.
Cocky guys were more willing to go toe to
toe with the competition, and usually weren’t
the first to blink.
Because they didn’t back down, they eliminated
the competition, and it’s easy to come in
first when you’re in a race of one.
The same held true for women; when they could
compete with each other, the more confident
ones drove others away and were more successful.
The researchers suggested the same arrogance
would translate to a crowded bar or club,
and the arrogant ones would usually come out
on top.
Get your mind out of the gutter.
This adds some food for thought to the age
old cliche that confidence is sexy.
And it is.
As Andrea Bartz explains in her advice column
on the Date Report, one of the many reasons
confidence is sexy is because confident people
are naturally good at selling themselves.
Not literally… well, I guess so too, I wouldn’t
know.
But when given the opportunity to present
just how great they are, confident people
took it and ran.
That confidence is more likely to help your
cause.
Confident people also make it clear they’re
interested in us.
According to Harvard Psychologist Dr. Craig
Malkin, when someone expresses interest in
us, we have a natural tendency to reciprocate.
But arrogance pushes people away and is generally
unattractive.
And like I said, it cuts both ways for men
and women.
Researchers at Webster University observed
women flirting in a bar.
Consistently the most successful approach
was a smile and eye contact, regardless of
what the woman looked like.
Another group of researchers asked some participants
to treat a shy girl like she was the hottest
thing since bacon, and over the course of
the semester she became much more confident.
By the end, students who weren’t a part
of the study were asking her out.
So when you fold in the new info from the
University of Queensland, It looks like there’s
an ideal balance of being confident just barely
to the point of arrogance.
Be confident to be attractive, and just over
the top enough to drive the competition away.
Of course no matter how confident and gorgeous
you are, you’re not going to be everyone’s
cup of tea.
Know when to take a hint and find someone
else to charm.
If you’re ready to get out there but you
still have no idea what you’re doing, Tara’s
got a brief guide on how to flirt better using
science here.